If you look at the products and services
that exist in this world,
sometimes it is truly staggering the
number of choices that people are given.
There is this feeling again amongst
people that I spoke to who,
who are known champions of simplicity,
that too much choice can actually
stifle,
uh,
customers enthusiasm or,
or stall the,
the selling process because you're just
giving them too much to think about.
So I just do my own casual research and
I,
because I'm a techie kind of a guy,
I look at like,
uh,
Dell's website versus hps and then
apples and it's,
it is quite extraordinary.
If you look at at Dell's website there,
I might get these numbers slightly
wrong,
but I'm pretty sure I'm right.
26 distinct models of laptops.
This was as a couple of months ago when
I last look.
Um,
uh,
HP has 41,
I believe it is an apple has three.
And what's extraordinary is that if you
look at the PC category,
um,
you know,
share of market,
apple never gets bored and like 10%,
but because they do these fewer things
better,
um,
their share of the profit in the
category is actually more than hp and
Dell combined.
So that lack of choice isn't really
hurting apple at all.
You might even say it's helping them.
You don't want to dumb things down and
you don't want to get people to feel
like they don't have enough choice,
but,
but you want to give them the right
choices as opposed to infinite choices.
You want to make it easier for them
simpler.
So I think apple has done a terrific job
of that.
And there are other companies in the
world that,
that treat their customers in that way
where it's actually a way of giving a
customer more respect,
um,
and demonstrating that you understand
what drives them because you're not
saying we don't know what you want.
So here's 40 things to choose from.
We're saying we get that you have this
particular need and this is a great
solution for you.
And that proves to customers that you
share their values.
And when a person feels that a company
shares their values,
they tend to give them their business
and that makes them more loyal
customers.
There's a lot of,
um,
concern at there for apple these days
that maybe it's losing its sense of
simplicity.
Steve jobs is gone and Tim Cook doesn't
share those same values,
whatever that product lines are getting
bigger and um,
it's less simple to choose what you're
looking for.
Product naming could be an issue.
Now this is where I'm going to start
sounding if I haven't already like an
apple fanboy,
and I don't mean to cause I try to be
objective,
but I think a lot of it is the result of
apple just being the most overanalyzed
company on Earth.
Because if you look at what they're
doing compared to what other companies
are doing,
it is vastly simpler.
I think what the real issue is is that,
uh,
audiences mature apple has tens of
millions more customers today than it
did when Steve Jobs was CEO.
And they're just,
there's a wide range of needs.
Um,
people say,
Steve would never do that when certain
things,
when in fact Steven did do that.
The ipod was,
this revolution changed the way we,
we listened to and discover music and it
was a super big hit.
And then a couple of years later,
therefore ipods and nobody had any
problem with that because that was steve
jobs doing it.
So now we had a tremendous hit,
have an iphone and now there are three
models of I funds,
you know,
they still got one more to go before
it's as bad as ipod was.
But the reason they had all those ipods
and the reason they have all these
iphones is because each one is for
distinctly different needs.
So to me,
that's not a sign of complexity.
That's just a company maturing,
having a larger audience and,
and,
and maturing a particular product line.
And the same is true of I ipads.
You've got the pro version for people
who need to create,
you know,
with the pencil.
Um,
and you've got more of a consumer level
IPAD.
So those things don't bother me at all.
Naming is a different issue because you
know,
you get like an iphone,
there's a success and a success plus and
an se that doesn't have a number on it.
Uh,
what's going to happen when the seven
comes out?
Is it still an se or is it going to be a
seven s II and what does it have two
letters and the other ones have one
litter and that kind of a thing.
It does start feeling a little bit like,
um,
like many companies out there,
big companies,
a lot of numbers and letters and that
part does not make me happy as just as
a,
as an apple fan.
I think it must be a better way to do
that.
Uh,
you know,
could be just like an ipad or Imac and
not have any number attached to it and
just,
it has a year in parentheses when they,
when they speak about it or when you get
service or whatever.
Maybe you just have an iphone or an
iphone plus,
um,
that sounds similar to me,
but you know,
who am I?
There's all kinds of behind the scenes
reasons why things happen.
But I think,
again,
whether or not something is truly simple
almost doesn't matter.
It's the perception of simplicity.
And I think today the perception of
simplicity with apple is a bit more
challenged there.
Those product issues,
uh,
which may or may not be an issue
depending on your point of view.
But then there's something like apple
music that has been generally,
uh,
not well received when it comes to the
interface.
It's an,
it's confusing.
Um,
and you do have to wonder,
how did apple ever released that
product?
You know,
why didn't they look at that?
And they have their super high level of
their high standards when it comes to
simplicity,
who didn't raise their hand and say,
I don't get it.
Can you make that more clear?
So I don't know.
I don't know what the answer is there.
I just think it's,
um,
maybe some growing pains.
Maybe apple needs a,
a minister of simplicity to oversee it
all.
Who knows?
But I don't think that apple is losing
its love of simplicity.
If you listen to anything,
Tim Cook says anything.
Johnny Ive says they're not just saying
things to try to fool us.
That's what they talk about,
making products that people can love,
and you have to have a simple product
for someone to fall in love with it.
So there's no doubt in my mind they have
the values they need to execute on the
values,
but I think they'll,
again,
the fan boy speaks.
I think there'll be okay.